[Music]
well very good morning to you
the prime minister is urging a heavy
dose of caution as the uk
takes a major step out of lockdown hugs
foreign holidays and socializing indoors
are back for many
as restrictions ease across england
wales and most of scotland
but it comes amid growing concern about
the indian variant and fears it could
spread rapidly amongst those
not yet vaccinated heathernan smith
reports on a big day on the road out of
lockdown
the doors are open so come on in at
midnight
rules relaxed this a comedy gig that
just couldn't wait till the morning
right now in my own head i'm in my own
room and i can finish this gig just by
going
distancing in the rule of six may still
apply indoors
but being back's a relief and a joy
i'm so giving the idea of seeing people
in the club welcoming them in you know
like there's something that happens
there's a magic that happens when an
audience comes together
and every everybody melts away and
suddenly your one laugh your one
kind of consciousness in a way without
sounding too kind of hippie about it
it's just nice to be part of a group
hugging and holidays are also now back
a coming together so many have craved
hello welcome back
at ghetto golf in birmingham they can't
wait for more mixing
like many they relied on a small outdoor
bar
but the key attractions are inside
having customers here
means having staff back to work we've
just
tried to keep our teams motivated
we're just now excited that it's finally
hospitality inside is opening
we can get all of the team back to work
in a safe way
and we're just we're all looking really
looking forward to it but
this is the backdrop and behind calls
for caution
surge testing in towns where the indian
variant is spreading
the prime minister has asked for
responsible enjoyment
how people respond could matter
immensely when it's opened up i'm
letting loose
i don't want to hear about the indian
variant to be honest because
i want it to open up and stay open i
want normality so i'm going to try to be
as normal as possible
but as safe as possible at the same time
and many have much rebuilding to do
empty airports speak volumes about an
industry embattled
cleaning regimes may be second to none
but with most destinations off limits
there's only so much they can do
pre-pandemic heathrow we would serve
around 240 000 passengers a day
and during the pandemic that has
absolutely fallen and in the trough it
was less than 10
000 passengers a day and we can't wait
to welcome passengers back
more turbulence is possible but it's
still a step forward
our old lives just may be in reach helen
ann smith sky news
well let's have a look in detail at how
the restrictions are changing across the
uk and wales is moving to alert level
three so from today indoor hospitality
reopens meaning six people from up to
six households can
book a table bowling alleys cinemas and
indoor play areas can all reopen as can
holiday accommodation
and museums and galleries international
travel can resume but the welsh
government
is advising people to only travel abroad
if it is
essential nothing changes in northern
ireland restrictions there won't be
eased until next week
most of scotland loose moves to the
lowest alert levels the exceptions are
glasgow
and moray they'll remain in level three
due to the number of covid19 cases in
those areas
for the areas in level one and level two
indoor socializing for up to six people
from three households is allowed as are
overnight stays cinemas and theaters can
reopen in those areas as well and pubs
and restaurants
will be able to serve food and alcohol
indoors until half
10. similar relaxations to the rules
in england from today you can finally
hug your loved ones and stay overnight
but the government is asking people to
be cautious about who you choose to have
physical
contact with indoor hospitality can
reopen
and up to six people from two households
can meet indoors
group exercise classes can resume saunas
and steam rooms
can reopen if you want to partake
in into any of that i mean it it is a
strange situation is it when you look at
how the different rules apply to the
three different countries i mean
the number of households who can mix it
is all a sort of strange situation isn't
it so you've got to pay really
close attention if you want to then
change your sort of habits from today
well let's get more details on all of
this we're joined in the studio by the
business
and uh the business secretary cartier
cuarte good to see you this morning
george
sneak as we look at all of this the
prime minister is talking about an
abundance of caution
in effect which begs the question if we
have to be that cautious why are we
changing the rules in the first place
so it's always going to be a balance and
that was the whole point of the road map
when the prime minister announced that
on the 22nd of february there were these
five-week
staging posts and the reason that it
took five weeks was that we had to look
at the evidence
today i'm very pleased that we're
reopening
but clearly in order to reopen on the
21st we're going to have to see
the data now there's nothing that we've
seen so far
that suggests that we're going to have
to postpone that but of course
there has to be some flexibility because
we don't know what the
coronavirus will do i think it's this
strange situation where i mean so mark
walport told
sophie ridge yesterday and he's a former
chief government scientific advisor so
my advice is just because you can do
something doesn't necessarily mean you
should
well in essence when things are reopened
people aren't going to
pay much heed to that are they because
people want to get out they want to
hug a loved one yeah i mean that's
completely understandable but
it's it's not that different what samark
was saying to
the prime minister's urge for caution
so yes uh things are being opened up but
people should
have common sense uh they should
use uh judgment and i think if we
act in a reasonable way there's no
reason to just suppose that we can't
reopen the economy entirely on the 21st
of june
i think it's got to be a degree of of
common sense bit of caution um
and not people you know people shouldn't
be running away
uh getting too exuberant i suppose i
think we just need to be measured
and cautious yeah i mean the problem is
when you when you rely on
the great british public to exercise
that common sense well that
that's all well and good and a lot of
people will but we all know there will
be people who won't
i mean and and this is potentially where
that you get your
problems and your hot spots isn't it yes
i mean there's always a balance as i say
and you can't
uh compulsorily uh lock everything down
forever
that's why we had a road map we want to
reopen in a safe
cautious way and i think this is a good
way to do that i mean will you be
heading out to a restaurant have you met
have you made plans have you made plans
to meet up and give some people a hug
but you haven't seen him for a while
going to be back in my constituency
uh i can't name the pub but it'll be
it'll be a lot of fun i'm sure
yeah but it'll be moderate i mean i'm
not going to be there with huge uh
hosts of people no well no i'm sure not
you would have
a lot of trouble if you overdid it and
can we have a look at the travel
situation because obviously again
a lot of people very pleased about that
um and and being able to sort of head
abroad for the first time
in in a in a long time but do you agree
with matt hancock who said just don't
travel to one of the amber countries
like spain yeah i think i think matt
obviously being health secretary is
firmly on top of the detail and the
numbers uh
and i think what he says makes sense
again uh people are allowed to do things
but it doesn't mean that everybody
should be
should be going away at the same time i
think the urge for caution makes sense i
think what matt is saying is that
yes you can go to another country but it
would probably be advisable at this
stage not to
i mean you sort of wonder if it would
have been more sensible if
if that's the general approach you know
the advices don't go
then why not just sort of ban travel to
any country that isn't on the green list
well of course you could have be
ultra safe and just simply forget about
the log uh
forget about easing up and just continue
with the lockdown we've decided that
that
wasn't the right course again there's a
balance between
opening things up uh urging people to
exercise caution
um and do opening things up safely and
that's that's a good balance i think
but in terms of that caution i mean
you'll be aware that i mean there's
there's a fair amount of concern of how
we reacted to
the india variant i mean the uh
civil aviation authority figure suggests
900 people arrived every day from india
between april the 2nd and april the 23rd
but it wasn't even on the red list so
they weren't even being put in a
they weren't even being put in in hotel
accommodation they they had to
quarantine and self-isolate and then
then on the 23rd of april uh we we put
it
um on on the red list before the variant
had actually been
identified um are we confident
that the the vaccination program is
enough to deal with the indian variant
have you got any information on that
um again matt hancock said yesterday
very clearly that he had a lot of
confidence
that the vaccination does work against
the indian
variant but of course we can't
definitively prove anything until
we've eased up and see what the the
actual data shows
and that's why we've got a degree of
flexibility but there's nothing in the
evidence now that we've seen
that suggest the vaccine uh isn't very
effective against the indian
variant i mean obviously we know that
the state of vaccination in this country
is very good
um but in in hot spots like bolton where
there is real concern over the indian
variant particularly in a place like
bolton
and they seem to be in a position now
where the vaccinating
anybody who wants it the sort of
encouraging anyone to come forward
do you approve of that does the
government approve of that no i think
the government has very clear guidelines
in terms of the ordered way in which we
roll out the vaccine and as you said
that's been working it's been a very
effective
uh roll out and we would suggest that
people should do it in in the in
in the correct order in the right way
would you i mean would the government
try to put pressure on
an authority like bolton to stop that
then i i don't know the actual details
of what's going on in bolton but i don't
think
uh you know we've got very firm
guidelines and we want people to follow
this
but it i mean what they're obviously
actively trying to do
is is stop the spread of the indian
variation monsieur amongst the younger
population and as a result
try to avoid the possibility at least of
a local lockdown
for that area i mean but if they if
if they can source the vaccines to do
that isn't that a wise approach
i can see what they're trying to do uh i
can see exactly what they're trying to
do but
what i've said is that i think there's a
really good way that we've managed to
roll out the vaccine you yourself
acknowledged
that it's been very successful and we
would suggest urge people
to follow the the guidelines that we've
set out and the method
that we've used within all of this um
obviously i mean
within within your remit i mean the
hospitality sector has been so badly hit
they're looking forward to getting up
and running a lot more at the moment
i mean there's a report claiming 10
percent of restaurants have closed down
the last thing anyone wants to do is
is reopen to be shut down again but
there's no guarantee is there
that that come june we may have to look
at all this again
yeah i mean we've been very clear that's
why they're with a five-week
staging post there's got to be
flexibility but as business secretary i
know and i hear it every day
the immense pressure that hospitality
and retail
uh has experienced i mean there's a huge
amount of
uh anxiety jobs people want to open up
the economy so that they can get trading
again and get back to normality and i
completely understand that
that's why we had the road map and
that's why i fully expect that will be
reopened
on the 21st of june you are you still
think despite the concern over indian
variant that
that could happen i think i think it's
very likely to happen i said that i
think the vaccines
are working against the indian variant i
think we've got to look at the numbers
so we've got some flexibility
but there's nothing that i've seen and
there's nothing the prime minister has
seen up to now
that suggests that we we're going to
delay that 21st of june date
i mean the problem is though is that you
look at people heading out and about
i mean it's not exclusively the younger
end of the population who haven't been
vaccinated
but it's more likely to i mean i'm i'm
in my 40s and i don't feel like going
out anymore
um it's it's yourself well i know
but it is likely to be the younger
unvaccinated people who are going to go
out isn't it yeah
look there are risks in this um and and
we can't say
now we can't guarantee that everything
will be
fine what we can do is and we've said
this consistently is that we'll look at
the data
and we'll make judgments according to
the data that we see so far so good
we're reopening
on the 17th of may as we said we should
in the way that we said we would
and now we have to see what happens
ahead of the 21st of june
i'm confident that we'll be able to get
to the 21st of june and open up
normally but i can't guarantee that now
okay minister good to talk to you this
morning thank you
now israel has carried out a series of
airstrikes on gaza
overnight following rocket attacks by
palestinian militants it follows a
warning from the prime minister
binyamin netanyahu that military
operations against palestinian hamas
militants will continue
with full force our foreign affairs
editor debra haynes reports from
jerusalem
israeli airstrikes smashed down on gaza
for a seventh straight night
israel's military said it targeted the
homes of
nine hamas commanders and a network of
underground tunnels
no word yet on whether civilians were
also caught up in the barrage
yesterday the deadliest so far for
palestinians in this conflict
this little girl had been trapped for at
least 10 hours in the rubble
reunited with her father a miracle
amidst
so much misery
but four of their family members
including three young children
among those who perished israel says
it's only going after palestinian
militants
but it's civilians paying the price
on the other side of the border more
hamas rockets fired towards israel
better protection here though as air
defense missiles blast many
out of the sky over the seaside city of
ashkelon
very frightening so is your house
damaged in my house
just a glass
suddenly a warning of incoming fire
[Music]
hello
steps back outside
rocket's not the only threat a man rams
into a police checkpoint
at a neighborhood in east jerusalem shot
dead
fury at a jewish legal attempt to evict
palestinians from sheikh
was one of the sparks to ignite this
crisis
hamas leader even name-checking the area
in a speech
warning israel's prime minister not to
play with fire
benjamin netanyahu not backing down
our campaign against the terrorist
organizations is continuing with full
force we make hamas pay a very high
price for their intolerable aggression
mounting devastation in gaza and rocket
fire on israel
underlining the need for urgent
diplomacy to broker a ceasefire
until then the pain grows debra haynes
sky news ashkelon
let's talk to our correspondent alex
rossi who's in jerusalem for us this
morning and deborah talks about the need
for diplomacy alex but i mean it just
doesn't show any signs of appearing at
this stage does it
well certainly there is a great deal of
diplomacy going on
behind the scenes but what is visible
what we can see
at the moment is certainly not
delivering uh
a ceasefire now the security council met
yesterday
uh afternoon all 15 members calling for
an immediate de-escalation
of the violence but as is so often the
case in the israel-palestine
conflict it reached no conclusion and no
firm action now that diplomacy is
continuing
today also the envoys from
egypt and qatar are working behind the
scenes as well talking to hamas
the israeli side is being talked to as
well by mediators from the united states
but as i was saying no conclusion yet in
fact
if anything the violence seems to have
been worsening
overnight now local reports in gaza
suggest that the
bombardment which started in the early
hours this morning by the israeli
air force was some of if not the
heaviest
uh bombardment that they have
experienced in this conflict with some
saying it's even heavier
uh than aerial strikes that they
experienced during the 2014
uh conflict now the israeli defense
force say they were targeting
homes of hamas operatives which they
claim were being used
as weapon storages but of course gaza
city
is an extremely packed populous place
and there will undoubtedly be as there
have been in the past civilian
casualties
now rescue teams are on the ground
surveying the devastation
we're waiting for those reports uh at
the moment
on the other side of course hamas is
continuing to fire
rockets into israel
and those are likely to continue as well
so no sign at the moment that this
violence is going to
stop and of course as it continues as it
escalates
it is civilians that are going to be
paying the highest price
okay alex thank you they're also making
the headlines for you
this morning and an assistant rabbi has
been hospitalized after being attacked
outside his synagogue in essex police
say the attack in chigwell
could have been religiously motivated
police in london have made four arrests
after a group of people waving
palestinian flags drove through parts of
london
shouting violent anti-semitic threats
it's believed to have happened in north
london's finchley road where there's
a large jewish community
officials in australia have denied
easing quarantine measures for a group
of cricket stars travelling
from india 38 players and staff
travelled via the maldives following the
suspension of the indian premier league
cricket australia says the group will
now have to serve 14 days in quarantine
the value of bitcoin has fallen by more
than six and a half percent overnight
after a tweet by the boss of the car
company tesla
elon musk whose company invested in the
cyber currency
suggested on social media they would
consider selling
some of their holding new research
suggests
regular gamblers are six times more
likely to bet online than before the
pandemic
the study found a decrease in gambling
overall but online betting
grew significantly over lockdown
now the government says it will not
support the nhs giving covered vaccines
to people of
all ages at present follows reports that
officials in bolton have been giving the
jab
to anyone following an increase in the
india variant of coronavirus in the
region well a short time ago the
business secretary kwasi kwaiteng told
me
that the vaccine should be given in
order of age
i think the government has very clear
guidelines in terms of
uh the ordered way in which we uh roll
out the vaccine
and as you said that's been working it's
been a very effective
rollout and we would suggest that uh
people should do it in in
in the correct order in the right way i
mean what they're obviously actively
trying to do
is is stop the spread of the indian
variety of monsters amongst the younger
population
and as a result try to avoid the
possibility at least of a local lockdown
for that area i mean but if they if if
they can source the vaccines to do that
isn't that a wise approach i can see
what they're trying to do uh
i can see exactly what they're trying to
do but what i've said is that i think
there's a really good way
that we've managed to roll out the
vaccine you yourself acknowledged
that it's been very successful and we
would suggest urge people
to follow the the guidelines that we've
set out
well let's talk to the mayor of london
sadiq khan good to see you this morning
can we talk about this to begin with
because i know there are there are 400
cases i think of indian variant reported
in the capital
so far would you support the idea
of just vaccinating all age groups now
well in general terms i understand the
advice from the government and the
experts to go by age
but actually in those parts of the
country where there are pockets of
people who have this indian variant i
think we should be nimble
and we should be giving the vaccine to
younger people in those areas
why because the early evidence is if you
receive the vaccine
less likely to catch this variant the
spread is less
serious but also the consequences should
you catch are less serious as well so i
think we should be nimble
and i've asked both matt hancock and
nazim zahabi the various ministers on
friday
to give us the flexibility to give
younger people the vaccine in those
parts of london
where we're concerned about this strain
i was going to say i mean for
somewhere the size of the capital i mean
you couldn't do it
across the whole population could you
and that's why i understand
what the government are saying and the
health advice across the country is what
we're saying though is uh
being nimble in relation to in those
pockets where we know there's an issue
let's uh use the vaccine sensibly so in
london the good news is we are now
testing everybody who's tested positive
the the the gene sequence see whether
they've got this particular indian
variance so we know
which parts of our city there's a
concern and so we should be doing
in those particular boroughs is having a
hyper local approach
and encouraging those who are younger
who would have to wait a few weeks to
have the vaccine
now to avoid this strain spreading i
mean do you have the authority to do
that
i mean could you as we're seeing in
bolton they just seem to have said we're
just going to do it
do you have that authority well it's
it's the nhs who administer the vaccine
they're working incredibly hard it's
been a great success with
local communities the nhs have got to
follow the advice from
up above that's why i approached matt
hancock and deemed hawaii on friday
asking for this flexibility which i
think is really important the the virus
isn't rigid and doesn't follow rigid
rules and we've got to be nimble
in relation to our response to it i mean
the the problem you're going to face in
the capital presumably is where you have
these
various pockets i mean one other thing
that is going to change today is you
we are going to see more people back on
public transport back on the buses back
on the tubes
it's going to spread isn't it well a
number of things firstly the good news
now versus the peaking last winter was
we have reduced
the amount of people with the virus by
98 we've reduced those in hospital by uh
90 because people made sacrifices but
also we finally have
an effective test and trace system so
anybody who tests positive we can
trace who they've been in contact with
and that's why i'm encouraging all
londoners and those across the country
test regularly you can get free lateral
flow tests test twice a week
as a habit and separately take a pcr
test regularly the good news in london
is
if somebody does a pcr test and they
unfortunately test positive we check
what strain they've got and also we
track and trace as well i mean obviously
today with things opening up i know
you're sort of heading a campaign to try
and get more people out about and eating
in london which a lot you know i know a
lot of people are going to want to do it
i don't think you're going to have a
huge amount of problem getting
persuading people
but i mean it's a it's a difficult sort
of circle to square
is there in that you've got you know
you've you've got to protect
the capitals businesses whilst
protecting the population
yeah look the health of individuals is
linked with the health of our economy
but here's the good news uh you know
cool bars uh
you know restaurants uh cultural uh
attractions
uh hospitality venues they work so hard
to make sure their places are covered
safe of course we're gonna still follow
the rules social distance wash your
hands regularly and thoroughly
uh we're a face mask you can use public
transport
but i think londoners and those across
the country are wearing to go
in a safe way so we've begun the biggest
domestic tourism campaign london's ever
seen encouraging londoners
to come back to the west end and
encourage those across the country who
may be a bit crustful and they can't go
in the international holidays don't
worry everything you need
is in london i was going to say because
that's that's ultimately the problem
isn't it with a lack of international
and
and national tourists and the hybrid
working which means people aren't just
popping out to buy a sandwich in the
lunch hour what have you
i mean that football is going to be well
down well here's the good news
this is probably the only spring and
summer when you aren't competing against
international tourists so you can go to
the world's best museums and galleries
not need to queue
you can get a booking at one of our best
restaurants without needing to get a
book in and it's really important
that we of course have a good time stay
safe but also protect jobs
and the reality is one out of five
londoners works in hospitality or
culture and so you can safely uh have a
great time
but also support british business look
and it's nice to have a positive outlook
i think we all want a little bit of ad
at the moment
um on the less positive front can i just
ask you about the anti-semitism
obviously
the situation that's going on in israel
and
gaza it is hugely concerning and people
can have their views on that
but what we have seen is some incidents
in london
and if you've seen the clips on youtube
and what have you i mean some absolute
vile language
which is which is anti-semitic
absolutely vile
now now what can what are you doing to
to protect to try and calm the
temperature on that and
and protect the jewish community in
london well i've been i've been in
contact this weekend with
both the commissioner and deputy
commissioner and the police are working
incredibly hard and it's important to
make for me to make this point
and it's possible at the same time to be
very angry about what's happening in
israel and gaza and the west bank and be
heartbroken
at the death and to call for a ceasefire
and a de-escalation
what's not excusable is on the other
hand to use as an excuse to be
anti-semitic and to be
racist there can be no excuse for that
so
jewish londoners in particular will see
in communities where they live
but also synagogues and jewish schools
and increased
police presence just to make you feel
safe but also to make sure anybody who's
involved
in any race crimes and they are crimes
by the way
action is taken and it's important for
us to realize that actually
the impact of this criminal behavior
has a ripple of fear effect on jewish
londoners and those across the country
and it's really important that we don't
bring conflicts 3000 miles away
to the capital city okay steve khan good
to talk to you
thank you now
next year celebrations will take place
across the uk as the queen celebrates
her
platinum jubilee there'll be an extra
bank holiday to mark 70 years on the
throne but now the royal family are
asking anyone
to plant a tree as part of the
commemoration our royal correspondent
brianna mills reports
the prince has planted a young oak tree
specially flown to canada
from windsor park for decades all around
the world
it's been part of the royal day job the
queen
planting more than 1500 trees during her
reign
so it couldn't feel more fitting that
we're all being asked to plant a tree
for her platinum jubilee it left me much
to do
[Laughter]
in windsor in march the prince of wales
watched by his mother
planted the first as patron of the
project whether you are
an individual hoping to plant a single
sapling in your garden
a school or community group planting a
tree
a council charity or business intending
to plant a whole avenue of trees
or a farmer looking to create new
hedgerows
everyone across the country can get
involved
one of the founding partners royal mail
have planted trees in every nation to
kick-start the project
but the rest of us are being asked to
wait until the next planting season
starting in october giving schools
villages businesses and
individuals the summer to plan the
woodland trust
giving away 3 million saplings to
support it trees are incredibly
important features of many landscapes
and
in this country we could do with a lot
more of them which is the whole point
of the queen's green canopy but on top
of expanding tree and woodland cover
across the country this is also a
celebration of ancient trees and ancient
woodlands
the queen's green canopy will dedicate a
network of 70
ancient woodlands across the united
kingdom and identify
70 important ancient trees to mark the
jubilee
but significantly it's also another way
of the royal family
again championing the climate change
agenda
we recognise that as a nation we have
huge numbers of challenges ahead of us
in terms of the climate crisis
and to be honest the best technology we
have for sucking carbon out the air
is the tree so if the 22 million people
who have a garden in their household
we're just to put one tree in
and everyone else we're just to
encourage uh to find somewhere else in
the country put a tree in the ground
then we'd be in a far better place to
address that crisis as well
next year will be an unprecedented
national moment
celebrating her 70 years as queen a
milestone never achieved
by any other british monarch marked by a
project that doesn't just look back
but is hoped will leave a lasting
environmental impact
for our future rhiannon mills sky news
now along with all the changes that are
happening today which of course
crucially involves hospitality
universities are also welcoming back
some students for face-to-face teaching
now many have been away from lecture
thesis
and their friends for more than a year
well
third year sociology and criminology
student jess herbert joins us now good
to see you this morning i mean
got to ask first and foremost is there
any point in you going back at this
stage
um for me personally no because my
lectures actually finished
on the 14th of may so
when the government did announce the
17th i knew that
it would be disappointing because it
wouldn't affect me in any way because i
would have just completely finished my
degree by that point
what impact has all this had i mean when
were you last there was it sort of
christmas time
um the last time i was there was before
the november lockdown
so the last i was actually there was
october so i haven't actually been back
to my campus since then
i just wondered what impact this has had
on your education do you think
um it has been difficult and i think
everyone learns
differently me personally i find being
at home
and online teaching really difficult to
engage with
so i definitely have missed the
in-person teaching
and i do think to some degrees it has
impacted
my work if anything and mental health
concentration
it's just everything has been affected
by it and of course university life
itself is different for those of us old
enough to look back at it with sort of
rose tinted glasses it's
it's more about it's more than just
about education of course
yeah it's really difficult um not seeing
friends for so long
and even to finish the degree and not be
able to
be with those people is really
disappointing
um i know it kind of is what it is and
there's only so much we can do
but it kind of feels like it's come to
an end really abruptly
and quite disappointingly i mean what
would you like to have seen
i think the the main thing would be more
communication with what was actually
happening
with uni students it kind of felt like
we were left in the dark
or were kind of a passing four
especially with restrictions easing a
lot of the time we weren't even
mentioned and it's just been a really
disappointing time to not have any
communication or know what's going on
and even to maybe acknowledge that from
the 17th
a lot of us won't actually be going back
yeah i mean it's all sort of ended with
a
bit of a whimper hasn't it which isn't
what you want
yeah it's it's it's been a bit of a
anti-climax moment but it just would
have been nice
for some communication to know what was
going on sooner and
even just to be acknowledged about what
you students are actually going through
at the moment
in all of this i mean all universities
themselves are in difficult positions
financially with a lot of this but i
mean if you had value for money for your
degree do you think
um i think that the uni have done what
they can
which i appreciate under the
circumstances but it is quite
i feel like you can't really deny the
fact that you are paying the full
tuition fee for things like
in-person teaching or access to
resources at the uni the library
and we haven't got that so i don't
understand why we're still being charged
the full amount when
online open uni is significantly less
money and that's essentially what we've
been doing
for a year and a half and what about the
rent situation
um so i'm very lucky i'm at i only
commute to uni so i
haven't had the stress of that but i
know a lot of people who have especially
when they were advised not to go back to
their flats
the stress of paying all this money for
a flat somewhere and then not even
having access to it
yeah yeah it's been a really tough time
for students yes it's good to talk to
you thank you thank you
now here in the uk the covid vaccine
program
has been rolled out according to age as
you will be aware but now the former
prime minister tony blair is calling for
all vaccines to be
evenly distributed globally so the
world's poorest
are protected sooner well tony blair
joins us now it's really good to see you
once again
this morning look this sounds like on
the surface a very honorable system but
how do you convince countries that now
is the time to stop
focusing on their own nations and to
look outwards
well they should do both i mean there's
no way any country's going to
give up its vaccines if it has vaccines
to vaccinate its entire population which
we do
obviously we've got to vaccinate our own
people really what we're saying in this
paper
is at the same time we should be making
sure that we're keeping vaccination
production going
so that we can vaccinate those parts of
the world that
present don't have access to vaccines
they urgently need them and it's in our
own interests that they do get
vaccinated
because the biggest problem we now have
is that even if we do everything
which we are doing now to vaccinate our
own people
if you get variants new um types of
covert disease that arise in different
parts of the world the risk is that they
then come back into our own country and
you can see this obviously with the
indian variant now so the important
thing is at the same time as we're
vaccinating
our own people what we do is we've set
out a plan a detailed plan for the
international community
to make sure we're maximizing production
and distribution
to all parts of the world at least so
that in those parts of the world that
are the poorest
and where they don't have enough vaccine
at present we vaccinate at least the
most vulnerable
the key workers and the big urban
populations because that will stop the
spread of the virus
to other parts of the world i mean isn't
this why is this down to governments
then rather than
just the the big pharmaceuticals and we
know astrazeneca for example have been
providing a lot of stuff
a cost price i mean why do the
governments need to get involved
because the the governments are the only
ones that can coordinate
how you increase the vaccination
production so for example
it's important to make sure that some of
the
the production of vaccine at the moment
has been vaccine being produced for
other types of condition
that we're repurposing some of that and
that really requires government to help
negotiate that with the big pharma
companies
so that you can increase the amount of
covert vaccine
and get it distributed you also need
government because
for example at the moment in africa
you've got about 1.2 billion people
you've got roughly i'm afraid at the
moment just over 30 million
doses of vaccine delivered for the
entire continent we need to make sure
that we're getting more
vaccine to the african continent by
maximizing
the supply of vaccine but the additional
problem you have
is that of that over 30 million
only a small part of it has yet been
actually
used for the population so you also need
to work with governments so that they're
able to absorb the vaccine
they're being given and vaccinate their
population effectively
i mean i was going to say logistics is a
huge
issue here are we going to be relying on
ngos i mean the
the charity groups that sector to to
actually deliver a lot of this
well some of it but but you can also
help governments is one of the things my
institute does is actually work with
governments
to plan a vaccine rollout you know to
have the
vaccination centers in the right place
so that you're actually getting the jabs
to the people who
who need them there's one other thing
which is important it's also important
here
we've got to combat the vaccine
hesitancy
i mean part of the problem we have is
that people who are entitled to vaccines
and who could get vaccines here as well
as
abroad are not getting them and you know
one of the things i've i've said
constantly over the last couple of
months
is that because britain is one of the
very few countries
but we're probably uniquely placed
actually because we're giving
vaccine physio vaccine which is the
messenger rna vaccine
and then astrazeneca which is the
antivirus vaccine
you're giving these two different types
of vaccine that are the two different
types really being used in the world
we have more data than any other country
in the world
which would allow us to say here are the
numbers that are being vaccinated
of those after vaccination how many have
got covered
how many of those have been hospitalized
how many of those have died
i think if we were to publish those
figures we would find that people would
see
it's absolutely clear one that you
should get vaccinated
and secondly that astrazeneca
specifically is a good and effective
vaccine
yes but the the problem is when it comes
to vaccine hesitancy some is
around safety issues and effectiveness
issues but a lot of it is cultural isn't
it
well some of it's it's cultural brazil
it's more to do with rumor
i mean you actually have a crazy
situation at the moment where you've got
african countries
turning away astrozenica vaccine on the
basis that it may have health problems
when the health problems from getting
covert
are self-evidently infinitely greater
than the problems that you may get in
very very limited numbers of cases
with for example blood clots so you know
in the end
yeah there are in some parts of the
world there are there are some cultural
issues
but by far the biggest problem is people
hearing rumors
stuff flying around the internet and
people thinking
you know i'm not sure i i should really
get vaccinated so for example a lot of
young people
will think look do i really need to get
vaccinated
you know if i get the disease i'm not
likely to get hospitalized or died
is it really important for me to do it
and the answer is absolutely it is
because you could still get even if
you're asymptomatic
you could get conditions further down
the line as a result of having had covid
and then of course you have the whole
issue to do with long cove which is a
a huge problem so it's really important
that we're saying to young people
particularly
do not think that this is just a disease
for people over 50 over 60
know it can affect you too and can i ask
you about the situation
in israel i mean obviously your middle
east envoy for a time
i mean how concerned are you by what
we're seeing at the moment and and
indeed by the role the uk is playing now
because we
from what we're aware we don't seem to
be really getting involved in this not
in a in a
sort of obvious way
it's a hard it's a it's a heartbreaking
situation um
stephen i mean
i am still involved in it um i have an
office um out in the middle east and we
still work
um on this issue you know
it's unless you deal with the underlying
problems
then i'm afraid every so often you are
going to get these conflicts that are
horrific in their consequence for
ordinary people
and you know the international community
can say whatever it wants to say about
de-escalation and stopping the conflict
the truth is it will continue for a time
at least
um but afterwards the single most
important thing
is that we get a viable clear
process for resolving the underlying
problems of the palestinian-israeli
conflict
and at that point at that point we've
got a chance then of avoiding future
conflicts
but whilst the situation remains as it
is this i'm afraid periodically
is what you get and it is absolutely
heartbreaking um but it will now
continue
for some time i think until
as it were you know the conditions are
right for a ceasefire
but that is only a ceasefire and what we
need is to tackle those underlying
problems
i mean i mean it's difficult i know i
mean there's a lot of international
concern i guess about engaging hamas in
in negotiation um is that something we
should be looking
at more actively
well i i have had um interactions with
hamas myself um look
hamas is an organization at the moment
are constituted
in a way that does represent a direct
threat to to israel
and if rockets are coming out of gaza
the israelis will retaliate that is just
the fact of the matter because their
civilian population
is under attack um the retaliation is
then
hard and that means also there's lots of
life in gaza
so it's the problem is that
you need a completely different approach
to this conflict now the thing that i've
worked on the last few years and
continue to work on
is that my belief is you're only going
to get a solution when it is a
region-wide
arab israeli solution and not simply an
israeli-palestinian solution
so you know we can i could go into all
the detail of that but it won't be time
but
the truth of the matter is if we don't
deal with these fundamental problems
including the nature of the threat
israel faces
including the situation of the
palestinian people as it presently is
the divisions by the way in palestinian
politics which are also a huge problem
unless you deal with these underlying
problems then
you know the international community can
wring its hands and people can look at
these pictures and be absolutely
appalled and want action to be taken
but the truth is there will be no
solution to this unless we get down to
the fundamentals
okay look just before we let you go can
i ask you about kirsten i know you've
commented about the state of the labor
party
uh over the weekend but um do you think
zakir has either the policies or the
charisma to to win a general election
well he's got the character and the
capability which are two really
important
qualities but you know look i don't i
don't want to
add to all the things i've said in the
in the past couple of weeks you know my
view of the labour party is that if it
wants to be a
viable opposition never mind a viable
government it's got to make fundamental
change
but you know i think it's best to now
that we've all had our say to let
here have some space to try and sort
things out i think he certainly got the
will and the attention to do that so
let's
let's give him that chance okay tony
blair
always good to talk to you thank you
very much indeed thank you steven
thank you